Welcome back.
It's a new year and it's time to set
new goals for ourselves.
Isn't that funny
how a calendar will give us the perfect excuse
to pull it together or make changes?
I love this.
And our next guest says she is ready to step into 2022,
but not without a new look.
Check this out.
Hi, my name is Susan. I'm 40 years old,
and Drew, I need your help. I need to make over.
I'm a busy mom of two, and between soccer and gymnastics,
I'm always in active wear.
I just turned 40 and I want to feel confident again.
After 16 years of marriage,
I want to look sexy again for my husband.
You won't believe this, but I don't even remember
the last time I went to the hair salon.
The last time I cut my hair, it was my husband who did it
and it wasn't such a good experience.
It's a new year and I'm ready for a new Susan.
That is hilarious.
(audience applauding)
I have to agree with you, Susan,
your husband did his very best with your haircut.
I love that you shared that with us.
It's so endearing and
I saw your video and I knew exactly who to call for help
because one of my nearest and dearest,
we call her a Drew Crew, but she's style and makeup guru
Zanna Roberts Rassi!
(adience applauding)
So, what is a good tip for us to
spruce our look up this year?
Well, I think the first thing we have to do
is literally stand in front of a mirror,
look at your body and analyze your favorite parts.
What do you really like? And then accentuate that.
So is it your arms? Then we're going to buy more sleeveless.
Is it your legs? Then we're going to buy skinnier leggings
and more heels.
Accentuate the areas you love.
Okay, well Susan's husband and hairstyler extraordinary,
Gustavo is in the audience.
(audience applauding)
Gustavo, What was the story behind the haircut?
How did that happen?
She wanted a new look and
she came to me with a ponytail.
And you do this and you cut this.
So I use my haircut machine
and then I tried to fix it with the scissors.
I mean, it wasn't that bad.
(man laughing)
Okay, well, are you ready to see what
Zanna did with your wife, Susan?
(audience applauding)
All right, here is what Susan looked like before,
just so we have a little refresh in our minds.
And Susan, please come out. Here is Susan now.
(upbeat music)
(audience applauding)
Beautiful!
How do you like it?
Give it a twirl.
Give it another twirl.
Look at this. Oh my gosh.
I always love Drew's face. My favorite thing.
And Gustavo's over there.
You like it?
I like it a lot.
(audience applauding)
Susan!
I think you look so beautiful.
Thank you.
You can take that picture out of the way.
All right. Take it away. It's gone.
Okay. I always ask this because it's my favorite question.
You look stunning. A 10.
But how do you feel?
I feel amazing.
Really?
Yes. This is the best way to start the year.
Definitely.
(audience applauding)
I will say, the month of December,
instead of presents and things like that,
I started to think, okay,
what did I do this year?
What can I do next year?
What (indistinct) better?
And actually this summer I was like, I live in New York,
I should go to shows and live those things
that I've never done before.
First thing that happens to me in 2022,
Drew Barrymore invites me for a make-over, so it's amazing.
(audience applauding)
Exactly. Now Zanna, walk us through
this beautiful transforming.
I mean, first off the hair.
I did not do this, we did not have Gustavo do it,
we sent her to a fabulous salon and they chopped off
literally a foot of hair.
And I do think with every inch you cut off,
you turn back the clock.
(audience applauding)
It's beautiful hair.
Beautiful hair.
And talk to me about this dress.
So there's nothing sexier my red
skin-tight, bodycon knit dress.
And then when it came to makeup, Drew,
we didn't want it to compete, so we just kept it
really nice and natural.
You have the most beautiful face and we wanted to just
bring out that structure, so
give the brows a little bit more definition,
a little bit of the flower beauty highlight
on the cheek there, look at that glisten.
I see.
Gorgeous.
And then a wine lip. It's simple.
You do not need to compete.
You are so beautiful and you are shining beautifully.
Thank you.
(audience applauding)
It's so true.
I definitely think, Zanna's the co-founder of Milk Makeup,
which is one of the best brands in the world
(audience applauding)
and I have to say,
you're exactly right, you chose a lip that does not compete
with the dress.
Va-va-voom.
Uh huh.
In the best way.
Yes, yes, yes.
I know.
Well, I just want to shout out Nordstrom
because they are the best company.
They've been so supportive of our show here.
They took care of Susan today.
But that's not all.
They want to give you a $3,000 gift card
to kickstart your wardrobe.
(audience applauding)
Wow!
So thank you, Nordstrom
always for having our back here at Drew Barrymore Show.
Here you go.
Thank you so much.
I'm coming shopping with you.
We're totally going for a little tour.
And Gustavo and Susan, please have a fantastic date night
on me, I want to send you to the theater and dinner
and all you can eat and drink and just the whole works
on me for a great night out on the town.
(audience applauding)
Thank you, that will be great.
Well, thank you, Gustavo and Susan.
Thank you so much.
and as always,
my partner in all things female empowerment,
Zanna Roberts Rassi.
We'll be right back.
(upbeat music)